he heard about this accident he came to
my apartment and we're right in the
middle of a podcast no i can't hold it
anymore
well alex sit in while your sister's
gone i want to have kids alex come and
sit in while your sister's gone what do
you guys think about pranking lindsay's
mom
i feel like we should do that we could
what should we say i don't know you tell
me you know she's a big fan she she
absolutely loved deal or no deal growing
up so she i told her wait your mother
loved dealer no deal growing up how old
am i yeah
my mom was a huge fan so we actually
should prank her what are you doing
posing posing for yeah
i need those i can hear everything in
here
that's lube
hey how you doing i never get to see
your face like straight on i'm really
handsome from that end wait a minute
you've never watched the podcast no it's
always like a like a decent i guess he
doesn't look straight that way look
right at the camera okay which camera do
you look at well actually see it's
moving right now yeah i see it yeah they
go
they move wherever it's up to us to move
the camera high tech podcast what yeah
cool is it moving automatically there's
a follow-up motion or is somebody
controlling it in there don't tell them
okay all right yeah really you've been
on this for how long now and now you're
just noticing i just noticed that it
moved i've never really focused on the
camera before and the camera has not
focused on you that's true so what would
we do if we called your parents what
would we do like
i'm not very creative can we announce
your engagement
she would tot she knows i'm on the
podcast right now so i feel like you
can't really prank her here's what
that's the problem you can't tell her
mother that she was interested i feel
like howie was the meanest guy like i'm
so pissed he was honestly so rude that's
not a prank she would be like oh my god
oh alex uh jackie did you finish peeing
yeah here you could come in you can come
back i haven't said anything he's like
this is like the academy awards he's
like
your brother is the seed filler
you did a good job alex you were amazing
yeah 10 out of 10.
and then uh caroline alex mandel makes
his first appearance on the podcast
and we should release that as a clip
yeah just this thing where he says
absolutely nothing jeremy that's alex
mandel on howie mandel does stuff
release the clip
[Music]